all right, quick story.
I don't want to spend a lot of time on this,
but it is funny and it's also sort of emblematic
of some bigger picture issue that we're dealing
with with the president.
This was one of those stories that when you
first see the headline, it's hard to believe,
but it is a very interesting microcosm of
the childish nature of the person who's in
charge of the white house right now and we've
talked a lot of times about how Donald Trump
in many ways is like a little kid.
They bring, bring them a propaganda, uh, at
the white house full of positive headlines
and pictures where he looks like an alpha
male because that placates Donald Trump, this
is kind of like how you treat a little kid.
The president presidential daily briefings
have to be reduced to, it was reduced initially
to just a couple pages eventually to one page
and then ultimately to a single page with
two or three bullet points and one or two
maps or graphs.
Otherwise Donald Trump won't read it or he'll
get distracted or he'll get bored.
Uh, the low attention span stuff.
And there is now a new report from the New
York times where former white house, dr Ronnie
Jackson says he was a blending cauliflower
into Donald Trump's mashed potatoes in order
to try to get him to eat in a slightly more
healthy manner.
And this is not like an investigative scoop
that may or may not be true.
Ronnie Jackson straight up said this to the
New York times during an interview, and this
was part of a bigger program.
Apparently a Ronnie Jackson wanted Trump to
lose 10 or 15 pounds.
He wanted to bring in an exercise bike or
an elliptical to the white house.
He wanted to make ice cream more difficult
for Donald Trump to get his hands on.
And yes, he was putting cauliflower into the
mashed potatoes of Donald Trump.
Now, this is not breaking news in the sense
that this doesn't affect the lives of people.
Trump's coronavirus response is atrocious
regardless of what is getting mixed into his
mashed potatoes.
This is not about the geopolitical embarrassment
that is Donald Trump on a daily basis, but
it is yet again another one of those little
details that shows us that at every level
at the micro, at the macro, and everywhere
in between, Donald Trump is like a child and
people around him deal with him like people.
People often deal with children.
I actually know people raising kids who hide
cauliflower in mashed potatoes, who make pizzas
out of cauliflower crusts instead of actual
pizza dough who will blend red peppers and
put them into marinara sauce when they make
pasta for their kids.
Much the same way that Donald Trump is being
handled here.
And when I saw the headline, I assumed it
was an absolute and total joke.
It's all too real.
This is real.
It's not about fat shaming.
This is about nothing other than in every
way.
World leaders deal with Trump, like dealing
with a little kid.
The people who need to brief Trump at the
white house deal with him like the low attention
span little kid that can only focus on stuff
for a couple minutes at a time.
There is nothing about dealing with Trump
that is like dealing with an adult.
It's all like dealing with a little kid.
When Donald Trump goes overseas, he has to
be managed like a kid because he'll get bored
at meetings with world leaders, the ones he's
invited to, he's constantly on his phone.
His attention drifts to a television with
Fox news on it at the back of the room.
It would be really great to have a president
who doesn't have to be treated like a child
all the time.
Who's the adult in the room and you know cauliflower
and mashed potatoes.
It's an almost irrelevant tip of the iceberg,
but it all is part of managing Trump.
Like the little kid he behaves as, and by
the way is is a little bit of cauliflower
in the mashed potatoes.
Actually going to help Donald Trump much when
he's obsessed with KFC and fast food.
I'm just asking the question.
I get that something is better than nothing,
but I just don't know if mixing in a florid
of cauliflower, florid or Florette, I guess
I'm never sure it mixing in a PISA or to of
cauliflower and to Donald Trump's mashed potatoes
is going to do too much for him one way or
the other.
Bizarre.
The, these are the times that we are living
in.